nous a fait comme dans fifa l
accélération double au stick droit
quel joueur je me suis demandé
s'il était même pas en scooter sur le
terrain tellement il allait si vite
[Musique]
mon père mon frère c'est des gens qui
m'ont toujours accompagnée ces des
personnes sans qui quand elles ne sont
pas là ou que je n'ai pas toujours au
téléphone c'est en manque de repères
[Musique]
m
sur le terrain on en est à plus de fans
[Musique]
je trouve qu'il y a très mature
c'est allé vite mais je peux vous dire
que ça peut aller vite dans l'autre sens
je profite et j'écoutais j'apprends
[Musique]
j'ai des origines africaines et pour moi
aidez le sport africain se développer
c'est quelque chose qui me tient à coeur
et si je peux aider à travers ma
notoriété même autre chose à pouvoir
aider le sport africain je le ferai avec
plaisir
[Musique]
c'est pour moi qui gère tout ça c'est
pas mon métier donc moi le prix c'est
pour moi c'est assez anecdotique
[Musique]
c'est pas moi qui ai internet c'est lui
qui va vite
[Musique]